BLUDGEON PRESIDENT TRUMP, A
DULY-ELECTED PRESIDENT THAT THEY
TRIED TO TAKE OUT.
AND MEANWHILE, A RADICAL GROUP
OF 2020 DEMOCRATS, THEY ARE
GETTING A FREE PASS ON VIRTUALLY
EVERYONE IN THE MEDIA MOB.
THAT INCLUDES SLEEPY CREEPY
CRAZY UNCLE JOE, HE IS SUPPOSED
TO BE THE EXPERIENCED, CONFIDENT
FRONT-RUNNER, IN A CROWDED FIELD
OF CANDIDATES.
IN REALITY, HE IS A WALKING
DISASTER.
AND BY NOW, WE ALL KNOW THAT THE
OBAMA-BIDEN RECORD, THAT WAS A
COMPLETE AND UTTER FAILURE.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT JOE, 30330,
WHICH MEANT NOTHING, HE IS A
NONSTOP HUMAN GAFFE MACHINE.
BIDEN'S PROBLEMS ACTUALLY GO
MUCH DEEPER.
RECENTLY THE
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER" COMPILING
A LIST OF THE SIX TIMES BIDEN
DESCRIBED MAJOR EVENTS IN HIS
LIFE THAT NEVER HAPPENED.
INCLUDING A WILD STORY ABOUT HIS
HELICOPTER GETTING FORCED DOWN
NEAR USAMA BIN LADEN'S HIDEOUT
IN AFGHANISTAN.
HE ALSO ONCE FALSELY CLAIMED
THAT HE WORKED AS A COAL MINER,
AND THAT HE WAS SHOT AT IN IRAQ.
ACCORDING TO THE 2010 BOOK "GAME
CHANGE," PRESIDENT OBAMA OPENLY
WONDERED "HOW MANY TIMES IS
BIDEN GOING TO SAY SOMETHING
STUPID?"
CREEPY CRAZY UNCLE JOE
REPORTEDLY TOLD OBAMA HE WOULD
NEVER HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT HIS
PRESIDENTIAL AMBITIONS BECAUSE
HE WAS "TOO OLD."
BUT FEAR NOT, BIDEN'S BRAIN
SURGEON IS HERE TO REASSURE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, 30 YEARS AGO,
HE PERFORMED SURGERY ON
THEN-SENATOR BIDEN FOLLOWING TWO
BRAIN ANEURYSMS, BUT TODAY, HE
TOLD ""POLITICO"" HE IS
ABSOLUTELY CERTAIN THAT HE HAS A
BRAIN THAT IS FUNCTIONING, A
BRAIN THAT IS FUNCTIONING.
OKAY.
GOOD NEWS.
BIDEN ALSO RECEIVED A GLOWING
ENDORSEMENT FROM HIS OWN WIFE.
SHE TOLD VOTERS TO HOLD THEIR
NOSE, SWALLOW A LITTLE, AND --
JUDGE JEANINE LAUGHING.
AND MAKE THE SENSIBLE CHOICE.
HOLD YOUR NOSE?
VOTE FOR MY HUSBAND?
IS THAT LIKE A NEW CAMPAIGN
THING?
ANYWAY, LOOK FOR YOURSELF.
>> YOUR CANDIDATE MIGHT BE
BETTER, I DON'T KNOW, ON
HEALTH CARE THAN JOE IS.
BUT YOU HAVE TO LOOK WHO IS
GOING TO WIN BACK THE SELECTION?
AND MAY BE HAVE TO SWALLOW A
LITTLE BIT COME AND, I PERSONALL
LITTLE BIT COME AND, I PERSONALY
LIKE SO-AND-SO BETTER, BUT
BOTTOM LINE HAS TO BE THAT WE
HAVE TO BEAT TRUMP.
>> Sean: HOLD YOUR NOSE AND
SWALLOW?
WOW.